donc on se presse devant de tous les
billets en recevant watch your soul oui
messieurs habitants c'est vrai que
d'abord nous voulions vous faire ce film
vaut être sûr que nous soyons déjà assez
vieux pour faire ce film est porté pour
faire ce film onf et au départ je ne
pensais pas du tout qu'on ferait une
suite si on avait imaginé une suite eh
bien on l'aurait proment fait un an
après la sortie du film est comme vous
le savez trop peu de gens ont vu ce film
donc finalement on a à l'époque on l'a
pas fait puis ce film au cours des ans a
trouvé son vrai public et à travers les
années et finalement j'ai trouvé on a
trouvé un scénario qui marchait on a
trouvé
un moment pour se retrouver ensemble et
finalement voilà le film a pris vie
parce que étrangement et bien le public
de ce film a grandi et c'est devenu un
film culte et donc en ce moment c'était
le bon moment pour le faire
alors question qu'est-ce qui est le plus
compliqué sur un tournage pareil est ce
que c'est de garder son sérieux ou de
faire parler anna wintour deux guides
avaient simplement simplement simple pop
hip hop c'est vrai que faire alors cela
veut dire qu'en fait ce n'était pas très
complexe que les personnages sont
finalement assez simple bien sûr on a
tenté de s'amuser pendant le tournage
mais surtout ce qui était le plus drôle
c'est de finalement faire venir en caméo
tous ces personnages du monde de la mode
c'est ce qui n'était pas le cas pour le
premier zoo länder où en fait on a
surtout volé les interviews qui était
prise sur le tapis rouge du championnat
alors qu'ici évidemment le monde de la
mode avait finalement vraiment s'étaient
amusés avec le premier film a le devoir
est donc cette fois-ci ana a vraiment
winter a été une vraie partenaires et je
crois que sa présence évidemment a donné
une tout autre dimension à juin le tout
appuyé winder ajouté s'il y avait quand
même un truc super compliqué selon la
chalosse fallait peut-être parfois les
vêtements qu'on portait le voile à
porter des vestes ou expérience était la
chose la plus complexe
just you you listening to justin
évidemment site après
hagai hadas charles h alors justin
disait videmment que c'était après tenir
sous les tropiques
quand on travailler ensemble dit bon bah
si tu es prêt si un jour tu as envie de
le faire sous l'un de deux bien voilà
j'ai envie de participer à cette
aventure et un an et demi à peu près
après ils ont commencé à écrire une
ébauche et déjà dès le départ il voulait
un scénario beaucoup plus internationale
qui se passerait donc ailleurs qu'aux
états unis et puis ils ont commencé à
échanger comme ça des blagues des idées
d'histoires et a commencé à l'écrire et
oen qui fait merveille aux journalistes
aujourd'hui 10 mai ce que justin dès le
départ vous aviez cette idée et justin
dit oui dès le départ on avait décidé de
vraiment reprendre la trame juste au
moment où hollander le premier s'arrête
et ensuite faire un vrai face fort oued
et ben de rajouter au fait on parlait
tout à l'heure des défis du tournage on
dit que verizon c'était une des
conditions extrêmes
eh bien nous aussi c'était assez
extrêmes pour owen et moi parce qu'ils
ont imaginé un tournage en italie
et comme on joue les top models pasta
interdite alors question ici en parlant
justement d'entraînement extrême j'avais
une question pour will ferrell mais
combien de temps d'entraînement voir
deux mois pour parfaire impossible
parfait café avec ses pieds à kofi à
philosophie
fellah donc extrême alors voilà excusez
moi moment d'émotion pour une femme qui
se rappelle avec nostalgie que son
mariage qu'il y aurait deux semaines à
kaffrine a lieu ici il n'avait pas assez
d'argent pour une pièce plus grande donc
voilà moment de nostalgie mais en fait
voilà ben may m'a appelé à peu près un
an et demi avant le tournage
en posant une question certes étrange où
il peut tu te débrouiller avec tes pieds
pour à peu près faire n'importe quoi
l'idée étant que ce n'était pas une dame
en écrit complément dans le script que
étant donné qu'il était en prison depuis
quelques années et qui ne pouvaient
utiliser ni ses mains ni en réalité il
fallait bien qu'ils se débrouillent avec
ça et voilà donc ben de racheter au
départ c'était juste une idée mais je
savais qu'il fallait lui donner du temps
d'entraînement pour qu'ils y arrivent
autre question bonjour c'est une
question pour ben justin le film
commence par le meurtre atroce de justin
bieber pourquoi lui
il ya ce que c'est jouissif de le
cribler de balles de match
alors voilà c'est vrai donc visiblement
vous en tout cas vous avez trouvé ça
jouissif c'est un peu un choix de textes
avec la feuille on fait les tâches voilà
pour le public car chacun finalement
réagi devant cela à sa manière et justin
de rajouter en fait on a écrit à peu
près il ya cinq ans lorsque justin tu es
bien bien plus jeunes et donc c'était
encore plus drôle nous dit alors
question ouais alors
zoolander firth la question pour chacun
des citations des répliques cultes de
chine qui eux les ont marqués non
max scarface d'accord le badge à celle
là je le gère chuck
mersen ça peut être le cas du crétin
mais je suis pas sûr qu'ils s'étaient
traduits par le crétin mais en tout cas
les références artbooks pour ben kalish
bien sûr qu'il regardait à peu près
qu'il y avait 15 ans il a pris tous les
monologues de bill murray ou l scarface
et justin calais chaque aussi autres
questions où un micro y aille a man from
belgium classe une forme est là et c'est
vrai que la question donc est-ce que ça
a été difficile de convaincre sting et
ben de dire que c'était en fait très
important pour nous de convaincre parce
que dès la première vraiment ébauche du
scénario
ils étaient une partie très un rôle très
important par rapport à la trame
narrative
donc il fallait le convaincu il a été en
fait la première personne que j'ai
appelé lorsqu'on a décidé de faire le
film et je lui envoyé le scénario il a
lu et des lendemain il m'a dit voilà je
j'y suis j'en fais partie et c'était une
des raisons vraiment essentiel sinon il
aurait vraiment fallu réécrire des
choses donc il a accepté
on vous voit tous complices tout en
train de rire entre entre vous vous
demandez que l'était le moment le plus
drôle pour vous l'écriture où la vie
dans cette voie mais l'envié oui mais
flash alors pour probablement le en fait
la réalisation les compris c'est à la
fois le moment le plus drôle mais aussi
le plus pénible parce que évidemment que
c'est très drôle mais en même temps il
ya tout le stress parce que évidemment
il faut donner le maximum en un minimum
de temps et donc on essayait vraiment je
te demande de garder ça une expérience
drôle et c'est en fait j'estime de
rajouter c'est vrai que l'écriture n'est
pas toujours le moment le plus drôle
mais lorsqu'on est là qu le scénario est
fini qu'on peut à peut s'asseoir parler
échanger des idées improvise
et ben de rajouter ses terres au moment
où tout est encore ouvert est possible
alors là c'est très agréable et owendo
rajouter ou enfin jusqu'à ce qu'on
arrive à la table de montage
voilà votre question oui ici ma question
est très simple je la fais en français
ce sera plus rapide
ja on avait beaucoup de célébrités dont
le film lesquels vous allez pour le
montage parce qu'on est déçu on n'a pas
vu kanye west on n'a pas vu macaulay
culkin comme s'étaient présentés ici à
bruxelles et new moon twilight c'est la
bride à goody se posent tous les mobiles
on se moque un peu mais miro
d'information bien sur internet nous
alors voilà c'est vrai que il ya eu
certaines célébrités qu'on voulait
pendant un moment et pourquoi pas par
exemple colline dans l'eau orji mais à
un moment c'est dit
bon c'est pas aussi parce qu'à un moment
c'est moi qui dois prendre le téléphone
et appeler ces gens là donc il ya
vraiment des choses qu'on ne pouvait pas
faire mais c'est vrai qu'on est très
heureux de tous les gens qui ont accepté
participer à l' aventure et en fait
quand on a regardé le film fini nous
mêmes on s'est dit façon c'était cela et
personne d'autre question bonjour il ya
plusieurs références à des films comme
star wars et une aussi qui pourrait
faire penser à d'autres ball est ce que
c'est un message caché ou quelque chose
et il y en a une au t1 action en justice
voilà littéralement première fois qu'ils
nient oui donc oui il ya des références
dont celle de star wars mais c'était en
fait simplement des références qui était
juste était drôle par rapport évidemment
contexte du film lui même question s'il
y avait un ou number 3 et que qu'il soit
tourné à paris et qu'il y aurait des
personnalités françaises que vous
aimeriez mettre dans votre film
la suisse a donc failli couler compris
que paris est ce qu on ya pensé non
vraiment c'est pas vraiment une ville
c'est un parti quand même que le film a
été annoncée hier
alors voilà c'est vrai que c'est à paris
qui a été annoncé le tournage et ben
disait que l'on fait il voulait annoncer
zoolander 2 sans vraiment l'annoncé
c'est un peu ce qu'elle fait où ils
pourront quand il avait lancé à comme
1-2 donc ils ont décidé d'avoir un
lancement un peu cool et il pensait
vraiment pas que valentino allez dire
oui et qu'ils allaient finalement se
retrouver à l'annoncé dans un target
avec ils sont six pièces de grandes
surfaces très énorme aux états unis
target
asus est question oui
david bowie était dans le premier film
je voulais savoir si vous aviez eu
l'intention de le refaire tourner et
quelques mots sur son travail sur le
premier film de 12 5% de tous elle coûte
du temps sur 100 m
alors on fait voilà c'est vrai qu' on ne
voulait pas on avait un moment pensé mon
ne voulait pas évidemment recréer une
scène dans le temps le numéro 2 qui
qu'ils soient enfin on voulait quelque
chose qui soit plus fort il était
impossible cette scène était si forte
dans le premier que du coup on est on
sait dit non ça ne marcherait pas c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui doit rester
unique et c'est vrai que je ne pouvais
pas croire qu'il ait dit oui parce qu'à
l'époque personne ne connaissait sous
l'un d'eux et je me souviens de cette
journée qu'il a passées sur le tournage
on a passé un moment merveilleux
ensemble j'avoue que j'avais un peu les
yeux qui brillaient un peu de vent
devant quelqu'un que j'admirais et
été incroyables tels qu'on peut se
l'imaginer c'est à dire un vrai
gentleman
autre question oui alors pour pour enc
évidemment après le show valentino et
bien ben a évidemment à tout de suite
postés sur les réseaux sociaux est donc
au n 10 et moi je connaissais rien il
m'a dit m'a vraiment guider atteint un
stade g c'est qu'avec les likes et tout
ça donc grâce à lui j'ai appris un petit
peu des choses sur les nouvelles
technologies
c'est vrai qu'en écrivant donc écrivant
le scénario il ya tellement de choses
qui se passent rapidement de gaza
c'était en 2010 et donc tout change en
cinq ans tout a énormément changé donc
en écrivant effectivement avec je me
tienne un peu au courant des nouveautés
qui se passait specter welding
évidemment que ce qui a été d'un très
malin dans cette suite c'est que malgré
ses dix années qui ont passé et bien on
a vraiment il ya une intelligence ont
selon un guide le public vous même
justement à est tout de suite dans le
bain du deuxième
c'est exact l'étude pointe son nez veut
faire de ce but
alors voilà donc voilà c'est surtout
quand il voit la facilité avec laquelle
sa fille se débrouille sur les réseaux
sociaux surtout snapshot pour lui c'est
tout maps tassé à manier difficile à ce
film et c'est à ce moment là qu
effectivement je me sens un petit peu
peut-être dépassé question alors j'ai
une question
ben stiller je me demandais si le
scénario n'est pas juste un prétexte
pour cacher le sens de penelope cruz
indécise
ok naciri
voilà c'était nécessaire pour le moment
du scénario avec un jeu qu'on est juste
ou pas je que javier bardem soit juste à
côté de la caméra autre question et
dernière question classe quoi c'est une
question pour ben ils jouent des hommes
qui sont super super beau mais pour eux
quelles sont les sommes les plus beaux
du monde et pourquoi youtube près une
croix sur cette affaire
très active mais franchement à mon fils
est plutôt mignon ressemble à sa mère
devient martinez olivier martinez aurait
donc d'un côté olivier martinez sport
est comme moi j'aime le sport je trouve
que les en général les athlètes et
sportifs sont plutôt beau gosse et bien
voila merci beaucoup et ils connaissent
alors voilà doublet compris dernier
souvenir mon ex beau père avait un peu
trop vu ce jour là et il a fait une
petite chute un peu brutal mais voilà
deux mais je veux pas trop trop parler
de ça pour pas vous casser le moral mais
vous vous au public aujourd'hui présent
bien vous avez rendu le souvenir de
cette salle et de cette pièce de balle
encore plus jolie pour moi voilà merci à
vous tous